Last time I finished up my lectures on
wise blood by trying to draw together
three different ways of reading the
novel into one interpretive framework.
And what I ultimately argued was that the
new critical formal unity of the novel
that is epitomized, I
think in a somewhat, uh,
perhaps heavy handed way in chapter seven
of the novel that's bookended by the,
the symbol of the blinding white cloud.
That it's that unity in
a sense that replaces the
bodily unity's that are always
blown apart in O'connor's fiction.
And in a certain way,
what you see is a fiction
that is personified in that
way that it takes on the
qualities and the values of the person.
And for O'connor,
that means the person understood in a
religious framework as something with
transcendent meaning and transcendent
value and indeed a transcendent life.
There's a very different image of
the personified word in Lolita.
And I'm going to refer now to an essay
in 1992 essay by the British novelist
Martin Amos,
he compares the [inaudible],
the prose style in Lolita
with a muscle bound man,
a man whose body is bulked up
purely for aesthetic reasons,
for only the purpose of looking a certain
way that the body builder is not that
person who's going to go out and
use their muscles to do some job.
It is simply there to be looked at,
to be oiled,
up and presented and displayed.
That's how Amos describes
the pro style of Lolita.
So I want you to keep
that image in your mind.
The question of the relationship between
the person and the aesthetic in the
Lita is going to be at the heart of my
overarching argument about the novel
today. You're not going to see much
of that. What I want to do today. Um,
since we have three lectures on Lolita,
what I want to do today is simply to
begin to open the text for you to give you
some ways of reading it, to alert
you to certain kinds of questions,
to ask you some overarching questions and
also to just get you thinking and into
the texture of the novel.
Um,
first I want to ask you though, uh,
what do you think of this so far?
I just want to hear from you.
What are your responses?
Who, who, who really hates this
novel so far? Anybody? Yes. Okay.
Why do you hate this novel?
I guess just because of the fact that
he's doing something that's really that
good and it almost seems
like it's trivializing it.
What about it trivializes that crime?
Um, I'm going to guess just that there's
no moral lens that we're looking at it
through.
It's just his deal with the world.
Okay.
So Humberto lack of a moral vocabulary
to understand what he's doing makes it
seem like it's true. Realized.
Okay. Other thoughts on this?
Who else is really put off by this subject
matter? Even if you like the novel,
who else was really put off by this?
Yes,
I agree with that.
I like it's disturbing how much you can
identify with her up like we're made to
see the world through his eyes and kind
of like even like I grew to like him,
like
presented.
He's a very likable character designs
and then it's kind of like good things
that you do.
He does are kind of on the side.
It's just like when you think
about it in like a very,
like the whole telling of the story,
it's like not objective at all.
And when you think of it in
an objective sort of way,
it's completely different story.
Okay, so, so you're,
you're suggesting is that what's so
disturbing about this is that we actually
like the sky, we actually come to
like Humbert. How many of you know,
I asked you this question
about a O'connor's characters.
Would you like to sit down
to dinner with any of them?
to dinner with Humbard?
And I would say this knowing that all
of us are outside the Nim fat age range.
So given that who would like to
sit down with Humbert and why?
Okay. Yes. You why?
Um, well, uh, simply because
I would argue that, um,
Humber in fact does have a
moral vocabulary and held
those terrible the things
he's doing are,
and yet we like him anyway and I think
that's the power of your novel and that's
why I making such a persuasive character.
Okay.
Do you think that Humbert really
believes that his actions are terrible?
Do you believe him when he
says, oh, I was so ashamed,
I was so awful. Do you believe
him? No. Oh, you don't?
Okay. All right. Does
anyone believe it? Yes.
Well,
sometimes he brings up these
classic failures that he
argues would have the same
interest.
And it seems like this dad,
you mentioned Virgil Dante,
it seems like this,
the desperation of bringing
up such like grand figures.
So makes me think that you guys have down
about what he's doing. Uh
Huh. Uh Huh. So, so the,
the authority of the Canon that he
invokes to defend himself in fact suggest
perhaps that he has some
doubts. Yeah. Hmm. Yes.
That's interesting.
I took this camera to the exact opposite
way [inaudible] is I thought that
essentially referred to the temporality
of our moral structure and how it's just
this arbitrary, um, coach our
societies and decided apartment.
Have you at one point in
time you've got Mansfield,
the end of the old Latin world
in the BC world, when, you know,
people can have these child slaves.
Right, right. Yeah. So, okay.
So this evidence is
very possible to see in,
in diametrically opposed ways,
and you're certainly not the first
two students that I've seen have,
have those two different reactions to
the same thing. What else do you, uh,
what else does this novel bring
out in you? What other thoughts?
What other responses
does anyone absolutely love this novel?
Okay.
Lots of you good. Why?
Who was a, tell me why.
Yes. Uh, the beauty of the
language and the imagery. I mean,
just the sentence structure,
the in choice,
I guess going away from perhaps the
theme. Um, more of just the language.
Okay. The language. Yeah, absolutely.
Even more about the way in which
it's not just that it's beautiful.
It's sort of like draws attention to the
power of words because of like you've
been sort of trying to ask us whether
or not we find him sympathetic.
And I think, um, in
this book we're sort of,
I'm reminded of how
words can make us feel.
Things can make us believe things that
are repugnant to us and sort of masks and
it's sort of like takes the mask off
literature and shows us the way we are
convinced.
Okay.
Takes the mask off literature.
Actually want to change that around if
I might. And play with that cause I,
that's a really useful image for us.
Takes the mask off literature and reminds
us how we come to be sympathetic or
how we come to think something.
Um,
think back to Richard Wright
who wants words to disappear,
to be completely transparent and to
leave you just with your response in a
certain way.
I would want to flip your image around.
It's as if Nabar cough allows us to see
the mask of literature to actually see
it.
They're probably doing its work so we
can become self aware of how we respond.
But how many of you didn't experience
it as understanding why you were having
that response to Humbert
but just having it,
were any of you sort of
experiencing this more like right?
Wants us to experience literature
to just have the response?
Anyone really seduced?
Yeah,
well I found that like wow,
I might have found that the pros
more or less like relentless,
like going back and forth in between
really trusting you these words and
banishing through that.
They were also points where I was
very aware of how they are, we feel,
but I think what I never really,
it was very difficult to escape to my
own like ration and you were very much
cemented inside with you. Like there
wasn't much of an escape from his,
which I thought was
okay. Yes. Do we ever
escape from his head?
You're saying that you don't,
you didn't feel like you ever could in,
in the world of this prose.
This is going to be an important question
for us as we think about what happens
to Lolita over the course of the novel.
Do we ever escape from the
subjectivity of Humbard?
Is there any way to access the
subjectivity of Lolita herself?
So this is one question you want to ask
yourself and if there are moments when
something like Nepal coughs,
voice or point of view shades into
hummingbirds, what are those moments,
if you think there are some, what are
the moments when that subjectivity,
this sort of prison of
that subjectivity waivers?
Where do you see those? I'll, I'll
leave that as a question for you. Well,
let me give you a little bit
of background. It's, it's, uh,
it's very helpful for me as I
address you to think about, um,
what you're seeing in the text and that,
that helps me to think about
what I want to say to you. Um,
so before I get into that,
let me just give you some background.
Some of you probably know a little
bit about in a back office life.
He was born in 1899 and his life to me
is fascinating because he was one of the
last generation raised in the old
aristocratic chateau life of Russia.
And it wasn't just a
Russian, uh, aristocracy.
It was really a very cosmopolitan
European aristocracy. Um,
he lived in,
uh,
in the summers on a country estate
outside St Petersburg and a beautiful
chateau.
And his uncle owned the chateau down the
road and actually left it to him when
he was a very young man.
Um,
so he actually owned
for a short time this,
this huge chateau and other relatives
and friends lived in the states
surrounding there is, it had huge
parks as part of its land, um,
where he first learned to hunt
butterflies and mount them,
and he became a serious
Lepadopa tourist. Um, as he,
as he grew older and was
very early in his life,
passionate about collecting
and classifying a butterflies,
um, in the winters, he lived
in the city in a, in a,
in a beautiful townhouse
in Saint Petersburg.
And he attended school,
uh,
only later in his life when he was
young, as was the custom. He had tutors.
So he had a French tutor
who lived with him, um,
lived with the family for a long time.
Uh,
he had Russian and English
tutors that came in succession.
He had drawing masters,
um,
and so on to cover the range of education,
thought to be appropriate to young man,
a young man of his station.
His father was a Democrat in czarist,
Russia,
and he was quite a reformer,
um,
at the time that the Bolsheviks
took over in 1919. Um,
there was a brief window of time,
um,
prior to the family's flight in
the family left Russia in 1919.
So the revolution I think starts in 1917
and things are quite complex in those
early days. So there's more than
one auntie czarist, uh, factor.
And his father was a Democrat,
but not a Bolshevik,
so he was Auntie's ours, but
he was not a Bolshevik. Um, he,
his father wrote for revolutionary
newspapers and he continued to write and
publish a newspaper even as an emigre.
He was assassinated in 1922 in Europe,
um,
on, on account of his publishing
activities. Uh, Novakof was very,
very fond of his parents.
Um, he has these luminous,
luminous essays about his
life as a child in, in this,
um, sort of perfectly
intact aristocratic world.
And in that picture,
his mother and father loom very
large and in a very fond light,
nearly invisible are
his, uh, or his siblings.
He had two brothers and two sisters.
And it's amazing when you read his
memoirs, um, how invisible they are.
Uh, this is one thing I find
striking about those memoirs. Um,
but it's an interesting thing to
ponder as we think about Lolita. Uh,
it's the image of a
person who is profoundly,
at least in his representation of himself,
profoundly occupied with what's
going on in his own mind.
His parents were very much
absent from his growing up life.
He spent a lot of time with his nannies
and tutors and nurses when he was
younger, his parents would travel. Um,
and his father was often away in the
city on political business when they were
in the country. So his parents loom large,
but not so much as physical figures,
uh, people he would interact
with in a daily sense,
but almost as icons or as or as
figures of the imagination for him.
Um, the real people he was sort of
with, certainly his brother's Sergei,
who he was educated with. His sisters
were educated in a different way. Um,
and we're somewhat younger than him.
Even Sergey is sort of invisible to him.
He wrote literature in Russian novels
in Russian when he was in Europe.
And then when he moved
to the United States,
he began to write in English and took
America as his adopted land and his,
uh,
English as his adopted language.
English was a native language in a certain
way because English was spoken in his
household all the time and he was by
an English governess as a young child.
So it, it's a deep, it's a language that
goes deep in his, in his upbringing.
It's not, um, it's not
really analogous. Um,
well I'm not gonna I, I'm not
going to get into that. Um,
it's not analogous to say Conrad who is
Polish and learned English and you can
see the marks and Conrad's fiction
of his having learned English.
And then as he's writing in it, it
comes across as a sort of clotted style.
And Conrad, some of the difficulty of
Conrad's style is the difficulty of,
of writing in this acquired language.
Novakof has none of that.
MMM.
So what I want to do now is
with that background in mind,
I want to take this up and just open up
the first few pages and I urge you not
to neglect.
Okay.
The forward by John Ray Jr.
So I hope you read it.
The little I tell size
forward and I want to focus,
especially on pages four and five.
Now forward is of course
supposed to suggest how you
should read the text that's
coming.
Um,
and so if we take it on in that role,
um,
let's see what we see.
I'm going to read a little bit of this.
This is on page four and five.
Okay.
For the benefit of old fashioned readers
who wished to follow the destinies of
the real people beyond the true story,
a few details may be given
as received from Mr Wind,
Mueller Ramsdale who desires his identity
suppressed so that the long shadow of
this,
sorry,
and sorted business should not reach
the community to which he is proud to
belong. His daughter, Louise
is by now a college sophomore.
Moana doll is a student in Paris.
Rita has recently married the
proprietor of a hotel in Florida.
Mrs. Richard F Schiller died in childbirth
giving birth to a stillborn girl on
Christmas Day 1952 in gray star,
a settlement in the remotest northwest.
Vivian dark bloom has written a biography,
my cue to be published shortly.
And critics who have perused the
manuscript call it her best book,
the caretakers of the various cemeteries
involved report that no ghosts walk
first. Let me point to you, uh,
you to this notation about
Mrs. Richard F Schiller.
I'm not going to tell you who that is,
but I want you to figure it out. Okay?
So make a note in your notebook
by the end of the novel,
I would like you to know who this is.
Vivian dark bloom,
Vivian dark bloom.
If you take those letters,
you can spell Vladimir Nabokov.
Vivian dark bloom is one of
Nepal coughs, um, Palindromic,
uh,
versions of his name.
He inserts these even in his
autobiography, by the way, he,
he attribute certain things to,
to uh,
Vivian dark bloomin' and other kinds
of characters have such names. Um,
so here you can't avoid the sense that
even though this is attributed to John
Ray,
in fact,
there is some other voice here and it's
a voice that can't help but drop the
name of lot of mirror in
Dubach off into the pros.
Okay.
So right away in this moment of layered
narratives and narrow a frame narrative
around another narrative,
there's a sort of instability
in the layers where is,
where is Nebach off here?
Yeah.
There's also the question of
what kind of reader we are,
that this preface brings up and
sort of puts in front of us.
Are we the kind of reader who is
interested in the real persons?
Well, it has this, uh,
it gives the, the, um,
the story that's to follow that sense
of being true because it suggests it's
fictional city as a thin veneer.
And that the real is something
that we can know about.
And I would suggest to you
that we can connect this
with
Humberto moment of wondering what happens
to the little girls whose images he,
uh, is excited by. This is on page 21.
I have often wondered,
beginning of chapter six,
what became of those Nim phets later in
this wrought iron world of criss cross
cause and effect.
Could it be that the hidden throb I stole
from them did not affect their future?
I had possessed her and she never knew it.
All right,
but would did not tell sometime later
had I not somehow tampered with her fate
by involving her image
in my velocity toss. Oh,
it was and remains a source
of great and terrible wonder.
Both Humbert and John Ray suggest
that the tissue between the fictional,
between the imagination
and the Rio is very light,
that it can be pierced somehow that one
can affect the other and I want to point
you to a a kind of language.
Yeah.
That also permeates between the
preface and the story proper.
And this is on page five.
This is the middle paragraph.
This commentator may be excused for
repeating what he has stressed in his own
books and lectures,
namely that offensive is frequently a
synonym for unusual and a great work of
art is of course always original.
And thus by its very nature should come
as a more or less shocking surprise.
I have no intention to glorify
h h no doubt. He is horrible.
He is abject.
He is a shining example of moral leprosy,
a mixture of ferocity in jocularity
that betrays do pre misery perhaps,
but is not conducive to attractiveness.
He is ponderously capricious.
Many of his casual opinions on the
people and scenery of this country are
ludicrous.
A desperate honesty that throbs through
his confession does not absolve him from
sins of diabolical cunning.
He is abnormal.
He's not a gentleman,
but how magically he's singing
violin can conjure up a tone dress.
How a compassion for lowly to that
makes us entranced with the book while a
pouring it's author,
you see that word throbs the desperate
honesty that throbs through his
confession. Throbs is a book, is a book,
is a word that Nebach off
brings out over and over
again in multiple contexts.
Always connected somehow with this novel.
Yeah.
So I'm going to ask you to read the
afterword on a book entitled Lolita.
Um,
when you read that,
you'll notice that the
word throbs comes back.
The first impulse to write this
novel is described as a throb.
The throb is of course,
undeniably associated with Humberto
rising desire in that physical way.
And there's that emotional
ISED version of that.
The throbbing heart of Romantic cliche.
Yeah.
It comes back and forth in his
memoirs to and speak memory.
That word appears. It's interesting
as the essays move chronologically,
they were written over a period of time
as the essays that were written near
Lolita come into the book.
That word appears also
describing various things.
It's as if that word really
embodies the feel of this novel.
And so like Vivian dark bloom,
that word suggest the permeability,
not just of fiction and the
real but these narrative layers.
Where is Nabar cough?
And I think he's there in that
throng is there in that throb.
Now I want to ask a question that
we're going to need to think about and
addresses the response of actually the
two of you sitting up front here. Um,
when I was asking you
how you responded to it,
can we have a moral response to this
novel and what would that look like?
Yeah.
Well John Ray asks us
to, and I want to, um,
just read part of that language
of morality that he uses.
I'm going to start on four and then I'm
going to skip down to the bottom of five.
Yeah.
Viewed simply as a novel Lolita deals
with situations and emotions that would
remain IX exasperatingly vague to the
reader had their expression been ETLA
aided by means of platitudinous
avail evasions true,
not a single obscene term is to be
found in the whole work. Indeed,
the robust Philistine who is conditioned
by modern conventions into accepting
without qualms a lavish array of four
letter words in a banal novel will be
quite shocked by their absence here.
If however,
for this paradoxical prudes comfort and
editor or attempted to dilute or omit
scenes that a certain type of mind
might call Aphrodisiac and then he makes
reference to the court case in which you
Lucy's was was ruled not to be obscene
in 1933 one would have to forego the
publication of Lolita altogether.
Since those very scenes that one might
ineptly accuse of sensuous existence of
their own are the most strictly functional
ones in the development of a tragic
tale tending unswervingly to nothing
less than a moral apotheosis.
The cynic may say that commercial
pornography makes the same claim.
The learned may counter by
asserting that h h is in passion.
Confession is a tempest in a test tube
that at least 12% of American adult
males,
a conservative estimate according to Dr.
Bland Schwartzman verbal communication
enjoy yearly in one way or another.
The special experience of h h that h h
describes with such despair that had our
demented direst gone in the fateful
summer of 1947 to a competent
psychopathology just there
would've been no disaster,
but then neither would
there have been this book.
In this part,
he suggests the possibility of
the tale ending in a moral tale,
a moral apotheosis,
but that's grounded also or hedged around
by the sense of psychiatry offering
other ways of understanding
what we think of as deviance.
But this is hard to take
seriously for a number of reasons.
Not least.
The Doctor Blanche Schwarzman
who is referred to here
it is of course Dr. White,
black man.
And it's referring to the Kinsey report,
the famous Kinsey Report on the
sexual habits of Americans. Um,
that came out in the 1950s,
um, Dr. Black white men.
It suggests that these are matters of
the heart that have been reduced to a
black and white set of statistics.
And you feel the absurdity of that 12%,
that number appearing in that,
in that sentence right here,
and I'm just going to skip down to the
bottom of five. Now, as a case history,
Lolita will become no doubt a classic
in psychiatric circles as a work of art.
It transcends its Xva, Xva tree, uh,
aspects and still more important
to us than scientific significance.
And literary worth is the ethical impact
the book should have on this serious
reader.
For in this poignant personal study,
there alerts a general lesson the way
we're child, the egotistic mother,
the panting maniac. These are not
only vivid characters in unique story,
they warn us of dangerous trends.
They point out potent evils,
Lolita should make all of us parents,
social workers,
educators apply ourselves,
was still greater vigilance and vision
to the task of bringing up a better
generation in a safer world.
Well,
aren't those ringing words from John Ray?
Nabar cough ensures that the very idea
of taking a moral lesson from this novel
is unavailable to us because
it's already been ridiculed.
He not only makes us see the psychiatric
evasion of morality as ridiculous as
Banal, as reductive reductive
to the black and white.
He ensures too that the language of
morality is the language of Cliche.
Yeah.
The status of cliche in this model is
one with which we're going to have to
struggle and I want to,
uh, move in that direction.
Now by turning to our first
hearing of Humberto voice.
What can we say about Humbert style?
If John Ray's style is full of certain
kinds of cliches that we can classify in
the ways that I have just done,
what about Humbert style?
Where does it come from and
why is it so enchanting?
So let's just begin with that first
chapter, the tiny chapter, chapter one,
Lolita. Light of my
life, fire of my loins,
my sin, my soul. Low lead top,
the tip of the tongue,
taking a trip of three steps down the
Palette to tap at three on the teeth.
Low Lee ta,
the first thing he does is make us feel
words in our bodies and especially in
the mouth and in the tongue
in that very sensuous way.
So that's the first thing
that his style does for us.
It makes us align ourselves in the way
that some of you were talking about
earlier,
not just to identify our minds with the
point of view of this particular person,
this particular character,
but actually to move your body and to
feel something bodily that he wants you to
feel, to share that sensuous
experience with him.
It's just the first little temptation
he wants to draw us in to the special
experience that he,
that he documents in his story.
She was low plane, low in the
morning, standing four feet,
10 in one sock. She was Lola in
slacks, she was Dolly at school.
She was Dolores on the dotted line,
but in my arms she was always Lolita.
Did she have a precursor? She did
indeed. She did. In point of fact,
there might've been no Lolita at
all had I not loved one summer,
a certain initial girl child
in a Princeton by the sea.
Oh, when about as many years
before Lolita was born,
as my age was that summer,
you can always count on a
murderer for a fancy pro style.
Ladies and gentleman of the jury,
Exhibit Number One is what?
The Sarah [inaudible],
the misinformed simple Nobel
winged Sarah [inaudible] envied.
Look at this tangle of thorns.
I'm seduced or you,
he's feeding us questions.
This is another thing to notice.
He's not just making us experience
Lolita's name the way he does.
He's assuming that there are certain
kinds of questions that we will ask.
Did she have a precursor?
Why is this the first question that you
would ask if someone was telling you
this story? Is that the first question you
would ask? So did she have a precursor?
No, probably not. Okay. Why?
Why does he want to plant
this question with us? Well,
he's working towards
something that he will also,
in some ways,
backhandedly does credit.
He's counting on us to analyze
him in somewhat Freudian terms.
So even though he will make a habit
later on of playing with psychiatrists,
staying at clinics extra weeks just to
bother the newcomers by giving them made
up dreams and primal scenes
to read and interpret.
Even though he's going to do that,
he still manipulating us because he knows
how deeply those kinds of exculpatory
narratives run with his audience.
Yeah.
So she had a precursor.
So what does that make any difference?
Does that make any difference to how
we're to judge him and we are the judges,
ladies and gentlemen of the jury,
we are in a way invited to judge
even though he's begging
us not to at every moment.
So it's a choice on Nabar coughs part
to foreground the question of judgement
from moment one.
Yeah.
And then for him to invoke
multiple kinds of exculpatory x,
I can't say that word.
Exculpatory narratives.
He's planting them in
there for us to find.
Okay.
Oh,
when in childhood.
By safely locating that precursor in
his own childhood when as he says he was
her equal,
where there was no crime.
Only a kind of infant tile passion
that nobody would blame him for.
He invites us to think of
Humbert as somehow still retaining a
kind of innocent purity that that passion
itself is the innocent purity that
flames at the heart of childhood.
Then we get these illusions and if you
have the annotated and little Leto,
or if you already know Po,
Annabel Lee is a famous poem by Edgar
Allan Poe and the Princeton by the sea is
a feature of it.
And so I'm going to read this to you and
there's a reason why I want to read the
whole thing. So, um, it'll just
take a minute. But here we go.
This is Annabel Lee.
Yeah,
it was many in many a year
ago in a kingdom by the sea.
That maiden they're lived whom you may
know by the name of Annabel Lee and this
maiden she lived with no other thought
than to love and be loved by me.
She was a child and I was a
child in this kingdom by the sea.
But we loved with a love
that was more than love.
I and my Annabel Lee with a love that
the wing and Sarah [inaudible] of heaven
coveted her and me.
And this was the reason that long
ago in this kingdom by the sea,
a wind blew out of a cloud by night
chilling my Annabel Lee so that her high
born kinsmen came bore her away from me
to shut her up in a separate occur in
this kingdom by the sea.
Okay.
The angels, not half. So happy
in heaven went envying her in me.
Yes, that was the reason as all
men, no in this kingdom by the sea,
that the wind came out of a cloud
chilling and killing my Annabel Lee.
But our love,
it was stronger by far than the love
of those who were older than we have,
many far wiser than we had.
Neither the angels in heaven above,
nor the demons down under the sea can
ever discover my soul from the soul of the
beautiful Annabel Lee for the moon.
Never beams without bringing me dreams
of the beautiful Annabel Lee and the
stars never arise.
But I see the bright eyes of
the beautiful Annabel Lee.
And so all the night tide,
I lie down by the side of my darling,
my darling, my life, and my
bride in her separate Kirk,
thereby the C in her tomb
by the side of the sea.
So that's the whole poem.
Humbert is drawing on
a 19th century romantic tradition
that still has a certain power.
You can hear that in cantilatory voice
of Poe's speaker in the poem making this
doomed love into something aesthetic.
But it's also a kind of cliche.
Okay,
if John Ray
okay
works with the cliches of
psychiatry and of social work
and in a way of politics,
progressive politics bring up a
better generation for the future.
Hummingbird has truck with
the cliches of the literary.
So he,
his is a vocabulary of
very high born cliches.
It's interesting when you read speak
memory in Dubach offs, autobiography.
He talks about his own experiments with
this kind of poetry when he was young
and especially when he was beginning
to fall in love with girls, uh,
that he would meet around
a Saint Petersburg.
He represents them as overheated attempts
at literature as dripping with a kind
of access,
romantic excess as essentially unable
to do more than repeat a tradition.
What Humbard has,
and I guess in a back off
has given him in the Po,
is not only that kind of overheated
romantic poetic reference,
he's also chosen of course
someone who married a very,
very young bride.
So Po,
I think at the age of about 2021
married his 14 year old cousin.
So for that reason po becomes a kind of
marble and he's the model in both ways,
both as a both as a pedophile and as
someone who imagined himself and his young
love fully clothed in
the language of romance.
So it's a kind of fairy tale,
the fairy tale language
that is invoked here.
The Princeton by the sea
is brought back for us
vividly in the scene where,
okay
Humbert first sees Lolita.
This is on page 39
great.
So He's walking through the house.
The haze woman is giving
him his tour of the house.
Okay.
I was still walking behind Mrs. Hayes
through the dining room. When beyond it,
there came a sudden burst of greenery.
The piatsa saying out my leader
and then without the least warning,
a see a blue seaweeds swells, sorry. Yeah.
A blue sea wave swelled under my
heart and from a mat in a pool of sun,
half naked, kneeling,
turning about on her knees.
There was my Riviera love peering
at me over dark sunglasses.
It was the same child, the same
frail honey, huge shoulders,
the same silky, supple, bare back,
the same chestnut head of hair,
a polka dot or the black current
chief tied around her chest.
He had from my aging eyes,
but not from the gaze of young memory,
the juvenile breasts.
I had fondled one immortal day and as
if I were the fairy tale nurse of some
little princess lost,
kidnapped,
discovered in Gypsy rags
through which her naked does.
Smiled at the king and his hounds.
I recognize the tiny,
dark brown mole on her side with all
and delight the king crying for joy.
The trumpets blaring the nurse drunk.
I saw again her lovely in drawn abdomen
where my southbound mouth had briefly
paused and those pure aisle hips on
which I had kissed the crenelated imprint
left by the band of her shorts.
That last mad day behind the rush rose,
the 25 years I have lived since then.
Tapered to a palpitating
point and vanished.
Yeah.
This is a remarkable passage to me.
He occupies in this passage,
every subject position of the fairy tale,
the nurse,
the hounds and the king.
She,
he's the nurse recognizing
the beloved child.
He's the king after her and
the hounds really after her.
At the same time,
I think we feel the freshmen freshness
of this pros and we feel the humor of it,
the self parody.
So even though he's counting on us to be
seduced by the romantic language that,
uh,
that incantatory trance of Annabel Lee,
there's a certain way in
which it's refreshed for us.
Like when he says the 25 years I've
lived since then taper to a pout,
Tate palpitating point and vanished.
That is not from the fairy tale.
That's his own voice.
One thing that Nabar cough does,
and I think this is related to the
way words like throb and the layers of
fiction and reality,
how these things permeate into different
texts and different layers of the story.
He always mixes originality with cliche.
He mixes the bad with the good.
He has a real disdain for
the black and the white,
that sense of simplicity
and so you're going to find
even at moments where I
think we're meant understand
Humberto pros as overwrought.
That muscle bound man
that aim is talks about,
you're also going to find
in those passages while
you're being just brought to
the sense of parody just to the edge
of what you can tolerate in that vein,
you're going to get a sharp sentence.
You're going to get a sharp
piece of very original pro style.
This is part of Nebach offs.
Talent is to manipulate you.
This is another way of manipulating you
is to make you see the cliche and then
to draw back from it to
something that surprises you.
So this is part of
part of
the strategy
and then watch what happens to the
pro style. And the difference in tone.
I find it most difficult to express with
adequate force that Flash, that shipper,
that impact of passionate recognition
in the course of the sunshot moment that
my glance slithered
over the kneeling child,
her eyes blinking over
those stern dark spectacles,
the little hair doctor who was to cure
me of all my aches while I passed by her
in my adult disguise, a great big
handsome hunk of movie land manhood.
The vacuum of my soul managed to suck
in every detail of her bright beauty and
these, I checked against the features
of my dead bride a little later.
Of course she this new val,
this Lolita,
my Lolita was to eclipse
completely her prototype.
All I want to stress is that my discovery
of her was a fatal consequence of that
Princeton by the sea in my tortured past.
And I think there's a reason why there
are quotations around that Princeton by
the sea and why it's
Po a fatal consequence,
not just of his early
love for Annabel Lee,
but a consequence of that poetry.
This is another kind of defense.
The poetry made me do it.
It's the romance that's
being offered in the poetry,
that lens his life,
it's course.
Okay.
So here the rationales
for his guilt and our forgiveness
of it begin to multiply.
Now I want to draw back from just being
immersed in those details of the text
for a minute to suggest to you that
this question of morality is something
that Nebach off deliberately.
Courts when to back off
was an exile in Europe.
He spent a lot of time
composing chest problems.
These are set setups of pieces on the
chessboard that have particular solutions
and they're very complex and they have
a kind of aesthetic form to them and he
would aim for certain kinds
of, uh, of elegance in them.
He never wanted to have
an alternate solution.
He always wanted to have
a single kind of solution.
There are certain themes in chess,
uh,
that refer to different kinds of strategic
movements that he would bring out
through these little arrangements and he
would spend inordinate amounts of time
organizing them.
Let me read to you how he describes the
action of setting one of these things
up.
It should be understood that competition
in chest problems is not really between
white and black, but between the
composer and the hypothetical solver.
Just as in a first rate work of fiction,
the real clash is not between the
characters but between the author and the
world.
So that a great part of the problem's
is due to the number of tries delusive
opening moves,
false sense,
specious lines of play
astutely in lovingly prepared
to lead the would be solver
astray.
But whatever I can say about
this matter of problem composing,
I do not seem to convey sufficiently
the ecstatic core of the process and its
points of connection with various other
more overt and fruitful operations of
the creative mind from the charging of
dangerous seas to the writing of one of
those incredible novels where the
author in a fit of lucid madness has set
himself certain unique rules that he
observes certain nightmare obstacles that
he surmounts with the zest of a day at
t building a live world from the most
unlikely ingredients,
rocks and carbon and blind throbbings
Lolita is, I think for an a back
off a kind of chest problem.
The chest problem is how can,
okay
Navarro cough make us
identify with a pedophile.
How can he produce from
these debased ingredients?
What Lionel trilling called it and you
have this blurb on your back cover the
greatest love story of our time.
Oh,
that's a question for you.
Is it the greatest love story
of our time was Lionel trilling,
a great mid century literary critic
was he used to do just by Humbert.
What would it mean to be the
greatest love story of our time?
But certainly nebach off has in
mind the rhetoric of love stories,
the shape of love stories.
And he's using those with all the skill
he can muster to try to make us enter
into the ecstasy that he describes at the
heart of this kind of logical problem,
the setting up of this logical problem.
So in a way,
we are the solvers of
this problem for him.
We are the other half that
completes the aesthetic experience.
We are there to
participate in it with him.
And on the handout that I've given you,
I'm not going to read it now because
we're running out of time. Um,
I'd like you to read that at home and
I'm going to refer to it later. Um,
the world of imagination on of
the aesthetic is very much, um,
on the surface of this text. And, and
you can see it in lots of ways, um,
to just in that little bit of the
first chapter that I read to you,
that sense of fancy, uh, fancy pro style.
So you want to think of fancy,
not just as a sort a
feminine ornamentation,
but as that older fashioned
sense of the word, the fancy,
the imagination.
So imagination is a
privileged realm for Novakof,
and it is around, that,
always has about it,
that golden glow. And if as you read, um,
as you read Lolita,
try to notice how much light imagery
there is for Nobach off sunlight,
golden Anness, all those
midges, the golden midges,
the downy golden hair on the Litas limbs,
her Tawney skin,
all that golden menace is very much of
a piece with the world of imagination.
So it's as if imagination makes everything
glitter and its color is that have
the most aesthetic of metals of gold.
So keep these things in mind as you read.
And in the next couple of lectures
you'll see more of the development of,
of argument about the book.
But I hope this gets you started.